après avoir régulièrement critiqué
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
donald trump joint les actes à la parole
la gestion de la pandémie par l'eau à
metz a vivement contrariées le président
américain qui a annoncé le gel de la
contribution américaine en représailles
le monde console oms pour travailler
avec les différents pays afin de
s'assurer que des informations précises
sur les menaces internationales pour la
santé soient partagées en temps opportun
et si ce n'est pas le cas pour dire au
monde entier la vérité sur ce qui se
passe de façon indépendante le web s a
échoué dans son devoir fondamental et
doit en être tenu responsable
le moment est venu après toutes ces
décennies washington 1er contributeur de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé va
ainsi privé d'institutions onusienne de
400 millions de dollars par an en 2010 8
22% des contributions de l'organisation
provenaient des états unis le secrétaire
général de l'onu antonio guterres s a
immédiatement déploré cette décision
ce n'est pas le moment de réduire le
financement des opérations de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé ou
de toute autre institution humanitaire
combattants le virus mais derrière cette
offensive anti om s c'est bien la chine
qui est visé washington accusé
l'organisation d'avoir aidé à dissimuler
la gravité de l'épidémie
dès son apparition sur le territoire
chinois fin 2019
du côté de pékin le jet de la
contribution américaine est donc perçue
comme une attaque directe la situation
épidémique mondiale actuelle et sinistre
nous sommes à un moment critique
cette décision des états unis va
affaiblir les capacités de l' oms est
miné la coopération internationale
contre l'épidémie
l' oms dénonce une politisation la crise
mais le coronavirus et déjà invité dans
la campagne présidentielle américaine
les points presse destinée à informer
les américains de l'avancée de la
pandémie sont l'occasion pour le
président trump de blâmer médias et
démocrates et parfois même de contredire
les analyses de son propre expert sur le
virus